okay in this video we're going to talk
about how to graph tangent and cotangent
sometimes students have difficulty with
graphing these I'm going to try and
break it down real simple so it's easy
for you to do let's take a quick look at
where the tangent and cotangent graphs
come from so we can recreate this in
case you forget basically if you
reference the unit circle again remember
tangent is the y coordinate over the x
coordinate so on the unit circle
tangents Y over x cotangent is the x
coordinate over the y coordinate so if
we want to graph tangent what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
negative PI over 2 if you go this
direction it's a negative angle to
positive PI over 2 you're going to
counterclockwise it's a positive angle
we're going to look at these points
along the unit circle and we're going to
get our tangent graph so let's go ahead
and do that right now so y equals
tangent of X okay if we start over here
at negative PI over 2 I'm going to the
left because it's negative and I'm going
this direction that's a negative angle
this direction is a positive angle so at
negative PI over 2 tangent is y over X
negative one divided by zero is
undefined can't divide by zero so we get
a vertical asymptote on our graph if we
go to negative PI over 4 right here
tangent is y over X negative square root
2 over 2 divided by positive square root
2 over 2 that's going to give you
negative 1 if you go to 0 tangent is 0
over 1 which is 0 positive PI over 4 y
over X is positive 1 and if we go to PI
over 2 0 over 1 is 0
sorry 0 1 is well I got I have my
coordinates messed up here this is at 0
comma 1 1 over 0 is undefined so you
can't divide by 0 so there's your
asymptote right there
okay so now when you look at your graph
tangent looks like like that so it gets
closer and closer to the asymptotes and
this will actually repeat like that and
like that
and so on so you can see from here to
here one cycle one period is pi so
remember for sine and cosine the period
is 2pi normally for tangent and
cotangent it completes one cycle and one
pi okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to look at what happens if
you stretch this graph compress this
graph and so on but before we do that
let's take a look at cotangent so we've
got the unit circle right here so
cotangent I'll put it right underneath
the tangent so you can kind of compare
and contrast cotangent we're going to
look at the points from 0 to 180 0 to PI
so cotangent x over y so one over zero
that's undefined you can't divide by
zero so we get a vertical asymptote at
PI over four x over Y is one because
anything divided by itself is going to
give you one at PI over 2 x over Y zero
over one is zero at 3 PI over four X
divided by Y negative square root 2 or 2
over positive square root 2 over 2 is
negative one and then if we go over to
pi X over Y negative one over zero is
undefined we get another vertical
asymptote for cotangent
the graph looks like that and again it
repeats just like tangent okay every pie
so--that's period is pi now what some
students remember is that tangents going
up to the right co'tin is going down to
the right
tangent half the graphs to the left of
the y-axis
okay 1/2 to the right whereas for
cotangent the whole graph is to the to
the right of the y-axis here okay so
kind of notice the difference so tangent
have some left Athens is on the right
side of the y-axis cotangent the whole
graph is to the right of the y-axis they
both have a period of Pi okay and you
can divide it up into four pieces like
we did here these are the basic parent
graphs okay so what we're going to do
next is we're going to look at the
stretching and compressing in the
shifting just like we did with sine and
cosine so let's just take a look say I
want to graph y equals two tangent of X
what do you think the two does to the
graph that's right it stretches it so
instead of being here at one you're
going to be up here at two now instead
of being here at negative one you're
going to be down here at negative two
this is a vertical stretch so it's like
you're pulling on okay stretching it
this way okay it's the same thing for
these okay now if we look at cotangent
let's say for cotangent we want to graph
y equals cotangent of 2x okay what do
you think the two does to the graph well
we can use this formula period equals
one pi divided by B this is the B value
- okay so what that means is completing
one cycle and PI over two so what it's
going to do is it's going to compress
the session going to divide the x-values
by two it's going to complete one cycle
like this now it's compressing it okay
and then you can shift it to the left
and right up and down so I'm going to
race this real quick and we're going to
take a look at some more difficult
problems but if you forget just go back
to the unit circle tangents y over x
from negative 90 to positive 90
cotangent from 0 to PI or 0 to 180
that's x over Y for cotangent and that's
how you can get the paragraphs and then
you can stretch them compress them shift
them and so on let's look at some more
difficult problems and you'll see what I
mean okay here's a good one right here
let's do y equals 1/2 tangent 1/2 X
minus PI plus 2 okay what I would do
just like we did for sine and cosines I
would graph the parent function using
the amplitude the a value and the B
value which affects the period then we
can pick up the graph and shift it right
pi remember this one has the opposite
effect this one has the same effect on
the graph plus 2 is actually up too so
let's start by graphing this one here
now I'm just going to start by graphing
the asymptotes I'm going to take the
period which is normally PI for tangent
and cotangent I'm going to divide it by
1/2 which gives you a period of 2 pi
because remember when you divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so that's like multiplying by
2 that's 2 pi but what I'm going to do
and this is what some students get a
little confused by half's on the right
side of the y-axis halves on the Left
I'm going to take this 2 pi I'm gonna
divide it in half so this is actually pi
here and negative pi giving you a period
of 2 pi I'm going to divide it in half
again these are like our midway points
PI over 2 and negative PI over 2 and
then the amplitude is 1/2 so we're going
to go up here to 1/2 and
let's let me erase this a little bit let
me just put a half over here and
negative a half down here okay
and so our graphs going to look like
this okay that's our parent graph okay
but then what we're gonna do is we're
going to shift it right pi and up to now
on our scale pi is actually two steps so
everything is going to shift two steps
to the right and up two steps okay so
what we have to do here is we're going
to take each of these asymptotes we're
gonna shift them right to so now your
asymptotes going to be right there
this one's going to go right here this
point is going to be go here and up two
so I'm just going to estimate for this
this is going to go right to okay and up
to I'm just going to estimate for that
and then this is going to go right to
and up two and so our graph now looks
like that okay the red graph so it
shifted right - and up - based on the
scale that we had okay so that's tangent
let's do a more challenging cotangent
graph the key I believe is to do it in
steps you'll graph the amplitude and
period in one step then you can graph
the the shifted graph in the second step
so let's graph this cotangent graph
let's just say we're going to graph y
equals negative cotangent let's just say
this is 2x minus PI over 4 okay we'll
just do this one a little bit more
simple so cotangent looks like this
there's the y-axis here is the x-axis it
goes down to the right like that it's to
the right of the y-axis where as
tangents halves on the Left halves on
the right the period is going to be two
pi divided by two I'm sorry one PI
tangent cotangent of periods normally PI
sine and cosine of period is two pi so
we take pi divided by two okay so that
means one period is going to be
completed in PI over two
I'm going to divide this into one two
three four pieces so this is PI over
four PI over eight and three PI over
eight okay so you could take PI over two
divided by four that's PI over eight and
that's going to give us our scale now
the negative what do you think the
negative does the negative reflects it
over the x-axis it makes the positive Y
value is negative and the negative one
is positive and what do you think the PI
over four does shifts it right PI over
four so everything's going to shift even
these asymptotes okay right PI over four
now on our scale that's going to be two
units to the right because we're
counting by PI over eight okay so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
first I'm going to reflect this so the
graph looks like this okay
and then it's going to shift right PI
over four so these points are going to
go one two one two one two and the
asymptotes also are going to go one two
and one two so your graph now is going
to look like like this
okay it's going up to the right because
it was reflected over the x-axis by this
negative here so that's cotangent we
talked about tangent and if you just go
back to the parent function like I said
do the a and the B first and then you
can shift it second you'll have the
graph down so that's tangent and
cotangent take a look at the graphs I
did on sine and cosine for additional
pointers and we'll take a look at secant
and cosecant in the next video